if I was given an opportunity to breathe
redesign the world
I think the first if I was given an
opportunity to redesign the world I
think the first thing which are you look
at is the fact that people so many
people have lost hope we talked about so
many things we talked about security
we've talked about developments we
talked about a whole variety of things
which don't take into account that the
core problem which were facing around
the world today is that there's a
substantive group of people who have
actually lost hope and because they've
lost hope because of the fact that such
a widening gap became a haves and
have-nots
it is these these are the causes of the
problems we have in terms of security
these are the problems which you have
with regard to the imbalances etc and I
think what we need to realize is that we
need to be able to impart a spirit of
hope amongst our people whether it be an
Africa whether it being the Middle East
whether it be in Europe and if we would
have work together to realize to try to
figure out how we can impart hope we can
we give impart a spirit that could give
people a sense there is a better being
out there that there is a better life
and that they could equitably get to
that life
I think this world would be a much
better place so I think the core spirit
of imparting hope on our people people
of the world as a whole should be the
fundamental basis behind redesigning
anything that we did we mean that we do
redesign whether it be the environment
security etc the core issue is hope